So now that the Republican National Convention
is underway, which will include the formal
renomination of Donald Trump as the Republican
nominee for president, accepting formally
whoa Miyo chair almost just fell, accepting
formally on Thursday.
Something stunning is going on.
The Republican Party is surrendering to whatever
the hell Trump wants.
And Republicans have announced they are not
going to be adopting any platform at this
week's convention.
Instead, they're saying we support Trump.
Now, some of you may know if you've seen conventions
before, it's not only typical, but it's really
one of the key things that is done at a convention,
which is that the candidate is nominated,
but platforms for the party are voted on and
established.
They're updated every four years.
The platform is modified as makes sense for
years of stuff has happened.
Now, what is really hilarious is that Republicans
are saying, you know, because of the social
distancing stuff, because we're doing everything
safely, we're just not going to do any kind
of platform update.
And we're essentially pledging allegiance
to whatever the hell Donald Trump wants.
Now, there's something very interesting and
specific to this year.
Policy and platforms are a problem.
When Donald Trump is your nominee, because
you've had four years of doing absolutely
nothing and in some cases supporting ideas
that run counter to much of what the Republican
Party actually has stood for on paper.
So Republicans have decided we're just not
going to unveil a new platform, period.
And hilariously, they're saying that it's
because the event is scaled back that they're
not going to do it.
The truth is, if they wanted to unveil a new
platform, there's nothing stopping them from
doing it.
It's the speeches that have to be scaled back,
or at least the crowds, the audiences, the
in-person stuff.
But a new platform could be developed.
It could be unveiled regardless of the format.
And instead, the Republican Party is pledging
to, quote, enthusiastically support the president's
America first agenda.
This, of course, is extremely unusual.
And even some Republicans are saying that
the party is essentially abandoning its values,
abandoning its principles in order to support
Donald Trump.
And that is indeed exactly what they are doing.
I mean, the Republicans willing to say that
are correct.
They've completely abandoned all of their
stated values.
And they're just saying whatever Trump wants,
he gets elected.
Republicans and the Republican Party are descending
into the same cultish behavior that Trump's
followers have fallen into.
And this is typical of authoritarians around
the world.
We talked earlier about Don Junior speech
where it's Trump alone can fix it.
Trump is the pretty just you just have to
follow and support Trump policy is irrelevant.
All that matters is everybody get in line
and support the Dear Leader.
And it's another step in the direction of
authoritarianism where there is no tolerance
for critical questions.
The group leader is always right.
The way to know the truth is to ask the leader,
what is the leader think?
And the other thing Republicans are probably
too dumb or too distracted to realize is that
by not changing their 2016 platform, they
are conceding that Trump has accomplished
accomplished nothing.
And I'll put it a different way to make it
really clear, they claim.
And Trump claims that he is the most accomplished
president in history.
They say and Trump says about himself.
I've done more in my first term than any president
in history.
And yet their plan for the next four years
is the same as for the last four years.
If the plan is the same.
You didn't do the things you said you were
going to do.
If you succeeded, you would want a different
list of things for the next four years.
It's all incoherent.
And and I'm obviously trying to apply logic
where there is no logic.
But this is fundamentally a cult that now
extends to the Republican Party itself of
people who are either too afraid to go against
Donald Trump or simply don't care as long
as they own the Libs.
And so they're going to scrap their platform.
Put aside everything they claim to stand for
and let Trump ramble for four nights in a
possibly I mean, just historically laughable
and humiliating Republican National Convention
and important always.
He could get another four years if we don't
act to prevent it.
He could end up with another four years.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
David Pakman and make sure you're getting
the daily audio podcast on whatever is your
favorite podcasting platform.